how long do you think a recession could
last six to twelve months darren cooper
um look most recessions end up if
they're kind of a shallow recession
could be you know 12 months uh you know
the official definition of a recession
is two consecutive quarters of gdp uh
contraction um but you know 12 months or
so is usually when people are affected
could go 18 a really bad recession be
like 24 months uh so kind of 12 to 24
months would be the historical uh norm
um but uh i i don't know i actually
don't know uh what uh uh what what is
gonna happen here i think that for most
people if you can get in a position
where you say hey i'm gonna be good for
like 18 months uh then you'll be in good
shape um how do i feel about investing
in energy or oil uh look i know people
who are fantastic investors in uh
kind of the energy sector i'm not one of
them i don't have any advantage they
don't spend a lot of time thinking about
it uh but i do think uh chris that um
yeah there's obviously a lot of people
who made money uh over the last couple
of months uh specifically uh with all
the geopolitical uncertainty and yeah
the world runs on energy so it's not
going to go to zero it's not going to go
away i think just trying to figure out
you know what's your advantage how do
you actually get
some sort of uh
you know exposure and what does that
look like what are your risk parameters
uh i'm not that guy but uh but there's
plenty of people out there that probably
can find that'll do it
um
sim asked what's your investing advice
for the next one to two years out what
are you investing in uh crypto real
estate commodities stocks etc so
definitely not advice i can tell you
what i'm doing uh but this is definitely
not financial advice uh i i've pretty
much uh outside of having to sell assets
uh to pay taxes i pretty much just buy
as many assets as i possibly can and my
goal is to hold them forever right that
that's my like overarching strategy and
so my current portfolio i've got um some
real estate i obviously have bitcoin
i've got a lot of exposure to private
market investing uh via venture capital
funds um either as an lp or or funds
where
i've managed to fund uh or as an angel
investor uh and then i um i pretty much
have no public market exposure other
than gbtc in a retirement account so i
don't think i have an advantage in the
public markets uh and it ends up not
being the risk reward uh that i'm
looking for so don't really play there i
don't have any um you know oil or any
sort of like commodity exposure like
that either so i'm pretty much real
estate crypto uh and then private market
investing uh and then also um i own uh
either majority or 100 percent of
businesses uh that have cash flow as
well and so from from a sense there's
investments there uh also and so when
you think about that over the next one
to two years
my situation like i'm gonna keep doing
what i was doing already uh i don't have
to make short-term decisions i'm i'm
relatively young i'm in my early
thirties uh and uh maybe i i'm creeping
into mid 30s i don't know when you have
to change saying early to mid 30s uh but
as you look over the next two years
nothing in my life is going to change
i'm not here retirement age in the sense
of uh all of a sudden now i should start
selling my portfolio to live on or
anything like that uh and um you know i
have the ability to assets i buy now if
they go down further i can just hold
them until they recover like i'm not a
force seller i don't have any major
issues so a lot of it will be i'll
continue to obviously uh invest in
bitcoin i'll continue to invest in
private market uh companies and i'll
continue to invest in real estate and as
i continue to do those three things from
a pure investment portfolio standpoint
i'll also continue to build companies as
well but that's why the strategy is
don't do that much different um and it
tends to uh to work out um because again
think if this is a 12 month situation if
you're making decisions today
and you're panicking but you could have
lasted for 12 months anyways then you
should be okay um and so i don't think
that you want to panic right now i don't
think you want to uh get in a uh a bad
uh situation